Konsistenz ist mega geil richtig richtig
lecker voll die schmeckt geil und ich
bin richtig geil ja
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute drei
ganz einfache ganz schnelle und super
leckere Pralinen die könnt ihr als
Geschenkidee oder Last Minute
Geschenkideen nehmen oder halt einfach
so schön auf dem Tisch präsentieren
jedenfalls sind sie wirklich sehr
einfach sehr schnell und daher lege ich
auch direkt los und schreibt euch wie
immer alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben
zum screenshotten und Einkaufen hier
unten in die Infobox ich starte mit
Snickers Pralinen und das werden dann
natürlich Erdnuss Schoko mit Pralinen
und alles ist super und kompliziert das
einzige was ihr gebrauchen könnte damit
schneller geht ist so ein Mixer meiner
gibt so langsam den Geist auf ist ja
auch schon gerissen und ich benutze sie
noch so lange bis er halt komplett
kaputt ist falls du sowas nicht habt
einfach ein Gefrierbeutel nehmen z.B
Kekse da rein tun und dann mit einem
Nudelholz drauf ein bisschen einfach
schön fein sind so jetzt gebe ich hier
einmal die Butterkekse und was gebe ich
noch dazu ich kann den Backkakao schon
mal dazu geben dann könntet jetzt noch
trinken nehmen der ist halt einfach nur
süßer oder um das komplett zu vermeiden
dass ihr gar nicht zwei Zutaten braucht
könnt ihr auch direkt Kakao ke
Unternehmen hatte ich jetzt aber gerade
nicht da und was ich auch schon mit dazu
gebe sind einmal die Erdnüsse dann nehmt
ihr am besten schon gesalzene weil die
einfach besser im Geschmack sind die
passen einfach besser zu und dann mixt
ihr das schön fein und gebt Kondensmilch
mit dazu und da bitte unbedingt die
gezuckerte Kondensmilch nehmen die kommt
dann meistens in so einer wie nennt man
das in so einer Konserve
[Musik]
so ich habe die Masse mal umgestützen so
eine Schüssel und jetzt einfach mit den
Händen kneten nur eine Minute oder zwei
und dann merkt ihr dass das so eine
richtig schöne leicht klebrige Masse ist
und wenn ihr zusammen drückt dann bleibt
es auch zusammen und so formen wir jetzt
einfach kleine Kügelchen ich glaube da
nehme ich mir einfach und das nehme ich
mir dann Esslöffel oder ein Teelöffel zu
Hilfe während Teelöffel und es ist
besser wenn ihr euch die Hände so ein
bisschen anfeuchtet und dann einfach die
Kugeln rollt und dann müssten sie noch
mal für 15 Minuten in den Kühlschrank
wandern damit sie einfach schön fest
werden und in der Zwischenzeit werden
wir aber schon mal die Kuvertüre
vorbereiten
[Musik]
so jetzt ärger ich mich schön habe ich
meine trilette Soße vergessen rein zu
tun oder er hat irgendeine Karamellsoße
aber ich mag die ja vom Geschmack sehr
gerne und ich hätte eigentlich noch
einen Teil von der gezuckerten
Kondensmilch durch die trilette Soße
ersetzt weil im Sneakers ist ja auch
Karamell drin aber ich habe gerade
gedacht es schmeckt auch so extrem gut
also macht euch da keine Sorgen ich
schreibe euch beide Varianten in die
Infobox wäre das jetzt für 15 Minuten
aber den Kühlschrank geben schön
Backpapier unten drunter damit da auch
nichts anpackt und dann machen wir wie
gesagt schon mal die Kuvertüre fertig
so damit wir gleich einfach auch
wunderschöne pralin haben und keinen
Grauschleier machen wir die Methode mit
dem Wasserbad das heißt ich habe jetzt
meine Kuvertüre schön fein sie mit
Vollmilch einfach weil bei Snickers auch
Vollmilch verwendet wird aber ihr
könntet auch natürlich Zartbitter nehmen
und dann gebe ich erstmal grob nach
Augenmaß zwei Drittel der Kuvertüre in
meine in meinen Schmelztopf ich habe
jetzt hier schon mal einen Topf mit
Wasser vollgemacht lass aber einmal
aufkochen dann gebe ich zwei Drittel
rein das ist schmelzen und rühre dann
das letzte Drittel dazu was dann in der
Rest Hitze schmelzen darf wundert euch
bitte nicht über die Außengeräusche
falls man hört wir haben nämlich eine
riesen Baustelle vor der Tür
die weck mich jeden Morgen Punkt 7 Uhr
manchmal auch 6:58 Uhr wenn die Männer
richtig motiviert sind
[Musik]
die Schokolade ist jetzt super
temperiert diese impfmethode ist einfach
perfekt dass sie wie gesagt keinen
Grauschleier habt und dass sie einfach
die perfekte Temperatur hat jetzt
aktuell müsste sie beachten 2029 Grad
liegen und eben nicht zu heiß
geschmolzen nicht zu langsam geschmolzen
sondern genau richtig so und die kalten
Kugeln kommen jetzt hier einfach rein
ich nehme jetzt zwei Gabeln wälzt die da
so ein bisschen drin das ein bisschen
abtropfen und dann kommen sie wieder
zurück aufs Backblech und dann habe ich
mir überlegt als Hinweis dass man auch
weiß was da drin steckt eigentlich
könnte ich auch so eine kleine habe ich
noch Mini Sneaker zum Süßigkeiten
Vorratsschrank könnte ich auch so klein
hacken drauf packen ne weißt du was wir
machen das so wenn ich Snickers habe
kommen auf die Hälfte der Pralinen so
abgeschnittenes Snickers und ähm auf die
andere Hälfte dann gehackte Erdnüsse und
was auch machen könnt ist so ein
bisschen Sarah läuft noch
ja du bist ein ich rede einfach Sachen
auf mit der Kameraden sein
da sind noch Sneakers gut dass ich so
gefräßig bin und so viel Süßigkeiten im
Schrank habe und was ich mir gedacht
habe bei den bei der Variante mit
gehackten Erdnüssen gebe ich so ein
bisschen Meersalz nach oben drauf geil
[Musik]
so während die Snickers Pralinen jetzt
gerade Aushärten bzw die Kuvertüre
drumherum machen wir schon mal die
kokospralinen ich habe schon ein Rezept
für Kokos Pralinen aber das ist jetzt
ein anderes weil ich finde es gibt halt
ganz viele tolle Varianten ähm das
andere Pralinenrezept ist auf dem
Kaufland Kanal online gegangen kann ich
euch gerne meine Infobox verlinken ich
nehme jetzt erstmal diese spekulose
Kekse da könnt ihr auch Kekse eurer Wahl
nehmen aber geschmacklich finde ich
einfach jetzt diese speculus Kekse super
passen ihr könntet auch Kakao Kekse oder
Butterkekse nehmen da kommen natürlich
Kokosraspeln mit rein wir können
natürlich auch ein dicken Esslöffel von
meiner Kokos cream mit dazu geben die
schmeckt wie flüssig geworden ist
Raffaello aber ich mache jetzt so für
Leute die sie gerade nicht da haben
sondern gebe ich noch Krokant mit rein
einfach für den Crunch
so und dann wird das Ganze auch wieder
gemixt und danach gehen wir auch wieder
gezuckerte Kondensmilch dazu
[Musik]
jetzt passiert eigentlich genau das
gleiche wie gerade auch ihr nehmt euch
jemand Teelöffel formt das Ganze zu
Kugeln das funktioniert auch hier besser
mit angefeuchteten Händen das mache ich
jetzt gleich auch und dann einfach aufs
Backblech und dann wieder 15 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank ihr könnt es auch länger
im Kühlschrank lassen also macht euch
jetzt keinen Stress ihr könnt auch eine
halbe Stunde oder Stunde wenn euch was
dazwischen kommt und ich würde dann aber
schon die nächste Variante gleich
vorbereiten denn da kommt gleich bei
beiden Varianten einmal bei Kokos und
später bei Pistazie kommt weiße
Kuvertüre außen herum und daher mache
ich dann eine große Menge Kuvertüre ich
habe zweimal das wäre Quatsch und dann
können wir alles zusammen fertigstellen
[Musik]
so für die Pistazien Pralinen habe ich
hier meine weiße Kuvertüre die wird
jetzt schon mal fein gehackt bei den
Pralinen des Kuvertüre in der Praline
und außen das ist so ein richtig schöner
weißer Traum so und ich habe jetzt ja
auch schon mein Wasserbad wieder
hergerichtet also wieder den Schmelztopf
auf den Topf gestellt und das Wasser
wird gerade erwärmt ich möchte die weiße
Kuvertüre jetzt nicht auf einem Schlag
erwärmen weil so Kuvertüre ist immer so
ein bisschen sensibler sage ich mal sie
mache ich das hier einfach immer im
Wasserbad und da gebe ich gleich dann
auch schon Frischkäse mit dazu da darf
sich dann auch schön verflüssigen und
dann hacke ich auch noch Pistazien
richtig schön fein
[Musik]
so die Pistazien habe ich jetzt rein
gegeben und die Schokolade färbt sich
richtig schön hellgrün das sieht so
hübsch aus und alles ganz natürlich so
ich gebe jetzt hier noch gehackte
Haselnusskerne dazu damit die Masse auch
ja damit man sie einfach Formen kann ihr
könnt auch komplett Pistazien geben aber
ich habe einfach nur so auch an den
finanziellen Aspekt gedacht weil es ist
ja Pistazie ist eine relativ teuere Nuss
eine hochpreisige Genuss und daher habe
ich jetzt einfach noch leckere gehackte
Haselnusskerne mit dazugeben
so und dann auch wieder zu Kugeln formen
und die müssten aber für 30 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank also da reichen die 15
Minuten nicht da müsst euch auf jeden
Fall mehr Zeit nehmen
[Musik]
so bei diesem Pralinen dürft ihr euch
nicht wundern da ist halt die ganze
Konsistenz ganz anders als bei den
ersten beiden es ist schon sehr weich
und nach jeder dritten Praline müsst ihr
euch auf jeden Fall die Hände einmal
unterm Wasserhahn nass machen sonst
funktioniert das nicht aber jetzt kommt
der wie gesagt in den Kühlschrank und
dann werden sie schön fest aber durch
den Frischkäse eben nicht fest genug
weil wenn ihr den jetzt weggelassen
hättet dann habt ihr nur Kuvertüre und
dann weißt er wie ein Stein und das
macht er überhaupt keinen Sinn daher auf
jeden Fall den Frischkäse nicht
auslassen notfalls könnt ihr den
durchmascarpone ersetzen das wäre kein
Problem aber ich lege jetzt in den
Kühlschrank und mache in der
Zwischenzeit die Kuvertüre
[Musik]
gleiches Spielchen ich nehme wieder zwei
Gabeln schmeißt meine Pralinen einmal in
das leckere kuvertürebad und dann wieder
versetzen dekorieren diesmal dekoriere
ich mit Kokosraspeln und dann mache ich
das gleiche auch mit Pistazien nicht
überlegt meine pistaziencreme einfach
drauf zu geben oder einfach noch mal
dazu noch mal gehackte
ich schon fast gesagt wobei das ja auch
geht ne Haselnuss kleine drin aber ich
finde diesmal sollte man ein bisschen
mit Farbe spielen und was Grünes drauf
geben
[Musik]
also es fühlt sich an als hätte ich mich
gerade selbst beschenkt das ist
irgendwie voll das schöne Gefühl gerade
auf jeden Fall finde ich sehr sehr
hübsch aus sehr vielseitig und ich würde
mal sagen okay ich bin ehrlich ich habe
gerade zwischendurch schon mal gesnackt
aber ich probiere einfach mal für euch
also das ist die Snickers Praline
also ich hatte extra mir das so
durchgeschnitten dass ich nicht das
Snickers oben drauf habe und dennoch
wenn ich die Augen schließen und
probiere würde ich sofort sagen es ist
ein Snickers Praline einfach wegen der
Erdnuss wegen der Schokolade Konsistenz
ist mega geil richtig richtig lecker
feier ich so jetzt probiere ich mal hier
die Pistazie ich habe übrigens gerade
noch pistaziencreme einfach in der
Mikrowelle erwärmt bei geringerer Zeit
dann ein paar noch mal so sieht es noch
mal unterschiedlicher aus wenn ihr
einfach die Deko noch mal ein bisschen
anders macht
viel weiter sehr lecker sehr erfrischend
übrigens
Käse
wenn man jetzt wie gesagt den Fisch
gesehen hätte weil die Konsistenz wie zu
hart und so habt ihr eine richtig schöne
weiche leckere Praline Pistazie kommt
super raus natürlich ein bisschen
Haselnuss dabei schmeckt sehr lecker hat
ein bisschen was von dem Cheesecake weil
Euro erfrischend schmeckt Pralinen
nennen ja ich gönn mir
jetzt kommt die kokospraline mit den
Spekulatius Keksen ich liebe diese
Verbindung einfach spekulati Kekse Kokos
richtig geil ich beiß mal rein
kannst du da mal rein weil die schmeckt
geil und ich bin richtig geil ich freue
mich wenn der Hamza probiert wenn ich
ihm gleich im Europapark bringen seht
ihr dann in der Story auf Instagram ich
wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen beim Verschenken oder selber
vernaschen macht sie unbedingt nach in
der Infobox stehen auch noch mal wie
viele da rausgekommen sind wir schreiben
sogar immer die Nährwerte rein wir
machen immer Kapitel also wirklich mit
einem Daumen nach oben mit dem
kostenlosen Abo und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten Video tschüss
[Musik]